[Music]
this morning the power of scenery
frederick law olmsted and the origin of
national parks this book takes a new
look at one of america's defining
features what has famously been called
america's best idea the backstory of how
national parks came to be is often
misunderstood long associated with teddy
roosevelt the birth of our park system
took place long before our 26th
president came to office and while the
west has the most epic landscapes the
root of the idea started east right here
in new york with both mistake
and triumph
[Music]
they are the parts of our land that
indulge primal instincts to explore
leave us in awe
and always keep us coming back for more
no one does national parks better than
america
though when this nation was founded the
idea wasn't on anyone's radar there was
an early movement to try to have
americans catch up with europe with
cathedrals and castles and that sort of
thing you can't do it we couldn't do it
but we did have these wonderful
natural parks and their extravagance and
their beauty and when we saw that we
realized that could be our
batch of works of art a new kind of art
almost like found art
dennis drabel is the author of the power
of scenery frederick law olmsted and the
origin of national parks for a long time
the only public park space
it was cemeteries well and it shows you
how
burning the need was
for outdoor spaces like that born in
1822 in connecticut frederick law
olmsted pursued an early career in
journalism it was his travels to england
in 1850 that would reveal his true
calling
astonished by the public gardens at
birkenhead park near liverpool a newly
built sanctuary amid the bustle of urban
life he returned home with passion and
purpose to bring parks just as grand and
accessible to america
his first one was monumental at just 36
olmsted was placed in charge of
designing new york's central park
he also in collaboration with calvertvo
did prospect park in brooklyn
both were spectacular successes
olmsted burned for more olmstead was
quite a guy i mean he would drive
himself to work
to the point of nervous breakdown yes
frequently yes
why was he so obsessed
i don't know i think it was partly
because he knew he had a gift that many
that no one else really had but he
didn't i mean he didn't sleep
much there's a great line from george
templeton strong's diary about olmsted
driving himself like crazy and then
breakfasting on
coffee and pickles
breakfast the champions
[Laughter]
olmsted continued designing and building
including perhaps his most ambitious
project
in buffalo who comes here everyone comes
here that's how he designed them they
were democratic spaces
places for everyone stephanie crockett
is the director of the buffalo olmsted
parks conservancy you call them works of
art yes these parks are works of art why
works of art because that's what olmsted
called them the size of the space here
was the same as central park but the
concept was different
this time it would be 24 pieces of
greenery including parks and parkways
buffalo became the first interconnected
urban park system in the country
when you think olmsted you you think
central park people yes don't
necessarily think here
no they think because that was such a
great park you know
847 acres of park right and it was his
first and it was significant he changed
new york but when he came to buffalo he
took 850 acres here and turned it into
an entire collection as his work
continued olmsted was guided heavily by
lessons learned from the problems that
had developed at another national
treasure in new york
niagara falls what did niagara falls
teach olmstead and others it taught them
that you can't just
leave the fate of a great natural
resource to chance or to
the chaotic workings of a marketplace by
the mid-1800s niagara falls was overrun
with shady business people looking to
take advantage of tourists and spoil the
experience
olmsted and others lobbied state and
local governments to act
what did it take to clean up niagara
falls money
it took this and a state that was
willing to do it in a province as well
the province of ontario canada which
shares a border with the u.s at the
falls and new york state took over lots
on both sides to cut back on capital
excess
while the area is still far from perfect
it was brought back from the abyss no
self-respecting honeymooners in 1900
went anywhere but to niagara falls
olmsted turned his belief that
government protection was key and over
development could be disastrous
into what would become the charter for
another jewel of the american landscape
yosemite in california part of olmsted's
genius was the ability to recognize what
places needed to be shaped and changed
and which ones just needed to be left
alone that's right how did he
determine which was which
i just think he had an incredible feel
for landscapes the yosemite charter
became the model for democratizing
america's natural beauty and led
directly to yellowstone becoming the
first official national park in the
world in 1872.
today there are
417 park sites across the united states
covering more than 84 million acres
for national parks in america to have
continued success in the next generation
and beyond what needs to happen
i think there have to be more and i
think they have to be in or near cities
i think people
will that way not only get more of what
olmstead wanted the kind of
urban slash wilderness experience all
rolled in one but they will learn a kind
of a land ethic which might spread
frederick law olmsted died in 1903.
next spring america will mark not only
the 150th anniversary of yellowstone but
the bicentennial of olmsted's birth
stephanie crockett and many others
are more than ready to celebrate
with olmsted's 200th birthday coming up
how should people remember him
people should be getting outside and
enjoying nature and
taking a look around because he did this
with vision he did it with purpose he
did it for us he did it for us 150 years
later you know that's pretty amazing to
have that kind of vision
thanks buddy thanks happy happy 200th
fred
[Music]
thanks man buddy we
appreciate you
one of the reasons we did it right now
in fall going into winter here is
because you know when designers first
envisioned national parks they talked
about 150 million americans being in the
u.s there are nearly 330 million we've
talked about all the overcrowding issues
that can crop up at national parks one
of the reasons why it's a good idea to
sometimes to go in the off season right
around now when it's not crowded when
you can be cold but have a little space
it's okay yeah